well time now for the press preview a
first look then at what is on the front
pages let's see what's making the
headlines with the political editors of
the daily mirror and the sun pepper crew
and harry cole they'll be with us from
now until just before midnight so to the
front pages then starting with the metro
looks ahead to the government's
announcement tomorrow regarding its
plans to tackle the pandemic over the
winter months including vaccinating
children as young as 12. the telegraph
leading with the government's attempts
to reach out to parents to make sure
their children are inoculated the
guardian focuses on the prospect of
booster jabs for the over 50s another
announcement expected tomorrow and the
sun goes with the angles affecting both
young and not so young the headline jabs
blitz
the daily mail
previews tomorrow's announcements as
well return of the doom squad the paper
says
and according to the financial times
plans for a 15 billion pound bridge
between scotland and northern ireland
described as stupid by opponents have
been scrapped as the treasury looks to
reduce spending well let's bring in our
guests then for tonight pipa crew and
harry colbert come to both of you and
straight to your paper harry in the sun
jabs blitz um 12 to 15 year olds we'll
found out about uh we'll hear more about
a booster tomorrow is there a danger
that the prime minister is putting all
his eggs in the vaccine basket
well i'm not sure what what more um
what hope he has than that and obviously
we hear a lot about how the vaccine
means that this this winter will be very
different from last winter and if you
cast your mind back to the chaos of last
november and december where the prime
minister was telling everyone it was all
going to be fine we could all wait for
christmas he let everyone get down the
line of making plans and buying turkeys
and then all of a sudden there we were
you know four days before christmas
cancelling plans and back into lockdown
for months and months afterwards so it's
a real concerted effort by downing
street to almost make a sort of road map
plan you know be quite honest and candid
with the different options that the
public are facing should things get out
of control but all framed through that
narrative of the vaccine has made things
different so as john was just saying
there it will be
jab uh booster jabs for the m50s one
single shot of pfizer interestingly
regardless of what um
of what uh previous um uh dose you had
whether it's astrazeneca or moderna um
so obviously they're very confident the
fires are supplies but they're also very
confident that pfizer is the one that
tackles the the crucial delta variant
first discovered in india uh most
effectively now there's also i think
below the surface there's quite of anger
in the house of commons earlier and
there's some bubbling some tensions a
little bit on the jobs of 12 to 16 year
olds because obviously since the 70s
it's always been
a matter of law
that technically a child can over
overrule their parents decision on this
so big fight i think coming between some
schools and teaching unions and teachers
and parents about actually how is this
going to be administered who has overall
control um who will actually police
consent for these jabs if it is going to
be rolled through through school but
yeah jabs on the front line tomorrow but
a few other tools up there in the box uh
for uh to try and avoid a lock down
which i'm sure we'll be discussing
as the evening goes through
yes and your paper has certainly picked
up on the jabs fur
for those youngsters um lots of
questions in the house of commons for
the vaccines minister nadim zahawi on
parental consent as harry said but also
why is this necessary given an estimated
half the children have probably already
had coronavirus one suggesting one and p
suggesting 40 to 70 percent had already
had it and then others saying why have
you delayed you've missed the golden
opportunity of vaccinating during the
summer holidays so that they are better
off when they go back to school so
plenty of questions for the government
on this
yes and it does feel that there's been
it's been a long time coming these
decisions we knew that the booster
campaign the government wanted uh to
kick it off this month but you know
we're already halfway through the month
and they've only just made the
announcement now and equally with
children the government's been under a
lot of pressure since before the summer
holidays to both them from teaching
unions from the opposition
and some of its own mps to start jabbing
uh children uh younger secondary school
children over the summer holidays to
make the most of that of that time so
that they were protected by the time
they went back but of course it wasn't
it's not a decision which just rests on
ministers shoulders it has been through
various processes the mhra which is the
the medicine safety regulator
approved
jobs for younger for children some time
ago
so they decided that they were that it
was safe for children to get and then
the decision moved on to the jcvi which
makes judgments on on who should get
vaccinated and when
and they took their time deciding um
ultimately that the that particular age
cohort
um were it was marginally beneficial for
them health-wise to get the job but they
were looking at it in quite narrow
medical terms and they suggested that
the chief medical officers of the
foundations the uk then took a look at
the decision but in a much broader
context taking into account for example
the disruption to children's education
and that's the decision which we've had
today in which is making the front pages
of tomorrow's newspapers that the the
chief medical officers have returned
today and said we think that on the
balance of abilities it's better for
children even though the health risk to
korean virus is not that serious to them
compared to adults it's better for
long-term mental health it's better for
their education and they're not being as
disrupted as that has been over the last
18 months and overall it's beneficial
but crucially they haven't taken into
account the impact of that decision on
adults health and children's vectors of
transmission so
debate's likely to run and run i think
over over the next wee while as
individual parents
make decisions about whether or not they
want their child to have the jab
absolutely and and i don't know how old
your children are what's your feeling
about this just on a personal point of
view
my eldest is 12 so he will qualify and
we've always sort of followed the advice
on vaccinations we think it's important
that there's a collective move towards
keeping the population safe when it
comes to other things like for example
mmr
this particular one it you know we will
talk about it with him because he had
coronavirus over over the summer so he's
one of those children that have had it
so you know potentially would be
protected by natural immunity but we'll
definitely listen to what he has to say
about it our instinct is to is to get
him the jab well the nhs certainly
preparing to roll out a schools based
vaccination program invitations for
vaccination will begin next week we're
told possibly it'll all happen quite
naturally if it's all done within the
confines of a school but we'll have to
to wait and see just looking at the
daily telegraph um harry interestingly
they've
put alongside their article parents told
to get their children vaccinated another
article which says just 59 deaths
happened amongst double jabbed without
any other illness so only 59 fully
vaccinated people without serious health
conditions died from covid out of more
than 50 000 deaths in england this year
according to figures from the office for
national statistics i mean i suppose
that's why the government is betting on
the vaccines as the first line of
defense
absolutely and i think they've been a
bit of frustration
as people touched on with the with the
officials and the the regulators and the
advisory panels it got a bit slow israel
america certain european countries have
been jabbing their teenagers
um
for quite some months now and that that
sort of head start that britain had by
having such a successful vaccine roll
out sort of almost this time next year
sorry last year the set starting in
december
last year that sort of head start has
been caught up with a little bit because
we have been slightly dragging our feet
so quite a lot of relief in whitehall
tonight they're able to crack on with
this um and there is some suggestion
from tory mps in the papers tomorrow
that perhaps the you know uh witchy war
who you know had wanted to do this and
the jvci had been dragging their feet a
little bit he'd gone back and got the
answer that he wanted by broadening out
a little bit of the scope but regardless
of the the sort of into into warfare of
these committees and and experts the
government have got the result they've
wanted and they're pinning their hopes
on this they're pinning their hopes on
the on the vaccine drive the double shot
um sorry the booster shot for for very
elderly alongside the biggest flu shot
rollout this country has ever seen
throw into that some sort of
multi-million pound uh advertising
campaign that's about to hit the
airwaves in the coming weeks um
encouraging people to get winter ready
they're hoping that initial surge might
be enough to to to keep keep the
pressure off the nhs if there is however
you know cases continue to rise and
crucially hospitalizations
tick up and intensive care you know beds
because start to become scarce as that
as they do
you know normally in the uh in this sort
of season
then there are a few other levers
they'll be able to pull the dreaded
vaccine passports for venues of large
crowds you know the government said
they're not going to do that as they
suggested they would at the end of this
month but they do hold it they will hold
it in reserve as a as an option and also
then the return of masks on in public
places perhaps in shops perhaps in
schools
uh
and things like that and perhaps even a
return to to working from home we've all
just got back into the office and
already contingency plans are being
published uh tomorrow to suggest that we
might be back back in our front rooms
again um before too long um so lots of
lots of things they can do but i think
you'll be hearing and we've already
heard the sort of overture of this of
this is everything we're going to do to
possibly avoid a lockdown sergeant jaffa
was out on sunday saying he couldn't
conceive of a lockdown he can't see a
path to one and i think boris johnson
will make it quite clear tomorrow that
this is all about
about avoiding it and that you know some
restrictions may return but the massive
economic levers that they pulled before
of shutting down businesses and shutting
down schools and and uh you know telling
us all to stay at home i think touchwood
or hopefully thanks to these vaccines
remain a thing of the past yeah pippa we
don't have much time just very quickly
and on those other levers that harry
described there are many people who
think we should have already employed
them for example
you know a more mandating message on
face masks in order to get the cases
lower before we head into this crucial
autumn winter period
yeah but there's been a lot of pressure
on the government for example in schools
to have had face masks and other
mitigations in place before children
went back we'll see soon enough whether
they should have done if cases start to
spike dramatically as a result of kids
being back at school
face masks on transport is another one
there are of course other other
restrictions which they could have
brought in
or they could have continued with but
there was huge political pressure for
them not to and i think frankly the
public were feeling pretty fed up
time will tell whether that was the
right decision or not
okay lovely that was lovely and brief
thank you very much indeed we will take
a break and come back with this the
proposed bridge between scotland and
northern ireland runs out of road i will
remind you of that one in just a moment
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview uh with me now as you can see
peppa carrera and harry cole welcome
back to both of you and pippa the
financial times um johnson's 15 billion
pound stupid tunnel killed off uh by the
treasury tell us more
mrs dominic cummings said it was stupid
i mean this was one of these big
infrastructure spending ideas that the
prime minister
loved so much we saw when he was london
mayor when he was planning a an airport
over the thames estuary and uh to keep a
car over the thames he he has he loves
these sort of mitchell mitchell style
grand project a sort of a physical
legacy and he felt that this would be a
good investment of 15 billion quid
however the treasury thinks differently
forest johnson last week as we all know
announced the 12 billion pound a year
tax hike to pay for his nhs backlog
plans and potentially social care um and
the treasury in return has said to all
departments they ain't getting any more
cash and therefore you're going to have
to bring in some big spending cuts and
this 15 billion pound bridge um over the
irish sea to northern ireland uh which
boys wanted to do to to physically unite
the union as it were um looks like it's
not going to go ahead so i think we're
going to be stuck with the fairies from
um from strana to belfast for some time
to come interesting and i mean it's you
know it's a testament to him i suppose
that nearly every story we do is is
about boris johnson but the sad news
that the telegraph is reporting tonight
is that his mother has died the um
esteemed painter who had been diagnosed
with parkinson's in her her 40s
the telegraph suggesting has died quite
suddenly in hospital harry
yeah no sad news uh sad news there we're
awaiting i think a statement um from
from from the prime minister possibly
obviously
often uh avoids commenting to too
heavily on his on his private life and
his first life but i can't help but
think that this is yet another
um another chapter in the roller coaster
ride this prime minister has had in
office his brush with covid the pandemic
a wedding a new baby another one on the
way and now a horrible person lost so on
uh
on a personal level it's a sad story to
read tonight absolutely and one wonders
whether you know the big plan for
tomorrow it's the day of the autumn and
winter plan which gets us through
another difficult winter whether he will
feel able pippa to to appear or whether
he'll he'll draft in perhaps the health
secretary
yeah well the telegraph is suggesting it
was surprised we obviously knew she's
been ill for some time his mother but i
think anybody would understand that if
the prime minister's lost his mother
that he might not feel up to doing
anything particularly very public for
some time and you know i hope that
people do cut some slack for that
because you know he's a human like the
rest of us and i'm sure it'll be a very
very heavy loss for him